hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to sex drive I bet you
clicked on this video because you're a
big ol pervert well too bad for you
there's no sex happening here it's just
a respectable game about fruit driving
down the highway trying to build up
their juice and responding to totally
platonic texts from other fruit friends
skin it's games about fruity calls ok
let's go
what's that fun I actually had to play
it to practice it because it's kind of
hard not like that but do you know what
I mean oh boy you me and the DVD of PS I
love you Gerard Butler is a dream you
know there's no God I didn't mean that
sorry the carriage just went splat hmm
hey sexy spud stud what's up got my eye
on you not on the road okay bye least I
got this goat over here yes pumpkin and
the beets comes from out with your plums
out well if you Jim damn with your
e-mount crap who did I just murder
whoopsies do you want to go for a roll
hey as long as the sexy sexy roll yeah
yes Danny love tonight I can it's a
little tough building up all I'm a juice
when I'm killing everybody in the
neighborhood how do you like your salad
without dressing without clothes not the
dachshund un des not about salads
Oh God the bun and then always whisper
in your ear I have an infection please
don't
whoa is that your peel oh my goodness
okay that's great ah it's totally free
and clear for the entire way excuse me
excuse me everybody in the world did it
orange you glad I said banana sounds
appealing Oh sassy blueberry Oh crappy
don't worry I'm seedless that give me
gets me beary excited when I pulled out
my phone and see that doof waving at me
it's not cool
all right is that a banana in your
pocket or you haven't see me I'm all
bananas for you okay but okay all right
cool ready you're okay whoa granny
almost got splattered not in that way
cuz no no this is sexual [ __ ] oh it's
hard game I can do it I can get the high
score and who the sex drive game without
fruit sexy fruit I'm gonna rhyme when I
make this video I'm gonna try to make a
thumbnail about sexy fruit and I'm gonna
have to google that I don't want to know
what that pulls up oh oh
that makes my fruit ripe if you know
what I mean how do you like your salad
[Music]
spinner here that's probably a good idea
I'm a bounder oh I'm a okay all right
I'm not repeating that that's just dirty
see just the way I like it
okay cool oh excuse me excuse me
all these nerdy fruit ain't getting
nothing whoop Mickey I'll bake you all
night what is that sexy look at them
apples yeah yeah yeah oh it's fine hello
doof how's it going
clean up in Aisle 6 & 9 oh yeah I will I
will I don't flirt good oh [ __ ] sorry
have an accident don't know what
happened was weird
yep thirsty squeeze you want to get
there oh yeah I will
look at those buns all right let's make
a smoothie I can't all I can take and
leave your smoothies whoops I didn't
mean to do that
give them here okay show you I'll need
more bread and butter pickle firlock
laughs I'm bad at this not that this is
sexual I'm the sexiest just call me
sapphire crap god damn it a blobs [ __ ]
moldy what's your asparagus status crash
granny almost got splattered oh oh I
don't know what that is what's going on
what am I looking at why am I looking at
it mammy support me sapote was what's
mamey sapote yeah well I can't wait to
taste all the death I'm splattering over
the road why can't I just pick up all
the juice from the people I'm blowing up
blowing up blowing up I've added too
much fun with this game I'll bring the
raspberry damn it god damn it I'm so
unsexy just where I like it okay cool I
can make it I can bring this back
Oh only if Jim can join who is Jim
oh yeah look at that look at that road
okay
my matrix needs to think about what
often roll out [ __ ] oh god damn it oh
[ __ ] don't don't get in my way thank you
hello there hello indeed don't hear
anything okay I'm okay
I'm keeping it up I'm keeping it up all
night
well Lima touch your beans
I'll bring the veneer oh the granny
granny I don't want to think about you
and I'm thinking about my Vanessa stupid
but I really like it get out of the road
why you know it's actually not my fault
what don't worry I'm seedless that gets
me burying same less spitting please
okay Babs all I said
laughs it's a whole new meaning you
delicious bass I just give what what am
I looking at better not be a poop better
not be is the song saying I waxed my
pineapple at night I'll bring the camera
who you beat beat you beat on your chest
what huh long he's a sexy sexy roll okay
cool
I did that yeah I did wash my pineapple
at night well so I can roll
Oh hot Italian sausage that's not fruit
related at all related this an
educational game made by the government
can't wait to test our firmness thiis
his firmness is all over my windshield
don't know what I said I didn't even
read any of that god dammit I'm sexy I'm
a statue would okay so that was sex
drive I think at the end of the day we
can all say we're all a little bit
dirtier after watching this video and
I'm even more so after playing this game
so thank you everybody so much for
watching see if you can beat my
high-score maybe and as always I will
see you right after I google sexy fruit
I'm gonna do that hang on wait hold on
to your britches
everybody ready okay here we go sex wait
up nothing
oh my god that's amazing what is this
what is all of this
this is suggest to tab oh my god oh my
god it's it's nothing too bad it's just
all suggestive but as a safeguard I'm
just gonna blur the entire screen for
you guys wow that is I never knew I had
no idea no idea Wow kids don't Google
that don't do that don't do that don't
do that don't do it all right so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I'll see you in the next video
I'm sure we can find someone that
doesn't appreciate looks like
microscopes spell books making
inventories
Oh